one
two three
[Applause]
[Music]
here's what I don't understand how is it
taking this long for you to get a star
in the Hollywood Walk of Fame I don't
know but better late than never what
does this day mean to you it means the
world to me I'm so honored I feel so
blessed I know that I'm blessed I'm I'm
grateful to God I'm grateful to my fans
my family my friends Lynn Tracy Steve
everybody that just supported and Show
Me Love
you have had this incredible body of
work that has resonated with so many
people now a new generation what does
that mean to stay relevant all these
years because there's going to be little
kids are going to walk by and be like
Martin Lawrence oh I know I'm from Bad
Boys and there'll be other people who
say I've known from The Martin Show the
way people say from Def Comedy it's so
many things your movies come on what
means the part of me I'm over the moon
because it's just such a great honor um
and I'm I feel so loved I feel like the
love that I've given out I'm just
getting it back you know so I feel it
okay what can you tell us about bad boys
we don't know the plot it has the chance
to be the best one of them all and
everybody's doing their thing and we got
a lot of the team back from the last one
Big Willy's doing his thing is as always
and so focused and uh it has a chance to
be the biggest one you had joked a
little while ago that you were thinking
about making a Shanaynay movie with
Jamie what kind of love do you want to
send to Jamie as he is you know dealing
with nothing but love for Jamie I mean I
wish him the besties in my prayers every
night he's not only one of our best
entertainers we have out here but he's a
great person and he's a genuine person
so please pray for him and continue to
show him lots of love this means that
you will always be a part of Hollywood
you know I mean look you of course are
always a part but this for ages to come
people walk by what is that star what
would be like when you walk by the star
years from now
Smiles you know smiles and appreciation
thankfulness you know gratefulness you
know all of all above
[Music]
thank you